[Music]
welcome to the reason Round Table your
weekly attempt to inject libertarian
analysis into the statist news cycle I
am Matt Welch joined by Nicholas B Peter
suderman and Catherine mengu Ward happy
national school choice week my fellow
backpack funding enthusiasts
present howdy happy Monday
uh just a warning at the top uh that uh
my voice is a little bit bad and sorry
about that and Catherine is flying on
Percocet she has no idea what her name
is how to pronounce it
or anything else so just keep that in
mind we're going to try to torture her
as much as possible is that right
Catherine is that you didn't want me to
mention that right yeah that's yeah when
I told you that I was hoping you would
say it at the top of the podcast yeah
that's good all right uh we're gonna get
to some of that juicy school choice
stuff later in the podcast but first
let's talk about a scoop late last week
from recent Zone Robbie Suave if that is
his real name under the headline inside
the Facebook files emails reveal the
cdc's role in silencing covid-19 descent
the piece was brought out the same day
that we posted our March issue cover
story this is the miracle of long
magazine lead times people in case
you're wondering about the dates uh that
was also by Robbie on uh how the CDC
became the speech police documents
obtained by Mr Suave
um from the state of Missouri's lawsuit
against the bite Administration show
that the CDC kept tabs on Facebook's
moderation practices and regularly told
the company what the agency wanted it to
do such as suppressed posts that
asserted covid-19 leaked from a Chinese
laboratory throttle content suggesting
that vaccines may do more harm than good
among certain populations and indeed
flag anything that quote could
potentially cause vaccine refusal
Catherine if you can respond to this uh
we're going to get into various
interpretations of what this reporting
does or does not mean but just to kick
us off uh oh Editor in Chief can you
tell us what we have learned and why
it's important
sure they'll take home lessons as the
kids say
um yeah so this is this is a piece
actually
um that started as
um sort of a top level idea assignment
we basically said listen increasingly in
these debates about the kind of policing
of speech on social media there's
there's a blurring of the line between
government power
bullying what is called jaw boning by uh
some like enterprising thing tankers who
want to make that a thing and uh and
then just free association and this is
you know for those of us who really
valued the distinction between public
and private and want to make it as
bright a line as possible
um this has been kind of a challenging
moment and so the initial assignment to
Robbie was like listen just talk to some
people about this and do a feature story
that's kind of big thinky but as he
started working on this story it became
clear that it was really more of an
investigative piece it's important to
know what is actually happening within
these companies before we can adjudicate
what should happen or where kind of the
demands of the Constitution rest and
Robbie got a hold of these documents
actually pre Twitter files so uh it
ended up being kind of a moment where we
were seeing a lot of very very similar
stuff trickling out in the most annoying
format known to man a broken Twitter
thread and then another broken Twitter
thread and then like 50 more broken
Twitter threads but you know for me
these documents were challenging because
there is no smoking gun they don't have
smoking guns in them it is not a moment
where the CDC says
if you don't do this we will put you in
jail
um it's it's subtler it's softer and
it's for the most part willing in my
editor's note for the same issue I say
um that you know they're they're happy
they're clearly happy to do this and
maybe would have done it even without
the cdc's urging and so that again puts
us in a tricky position about where the
boundaries are of Free Speech but I
think it is clear that you know when we
have the president saying social media
companies are killing people there is an
implied threat and and so that's really
worth exploring and that's what this
piece does Nick there's been reaction
both to uh our Facebook files reporting
and the Twitter files in general
um that go along the lines of like look
it's a pandemic people are dying so
what's wrong with private companies
seeking the expertise the consultation
from well-informed government bodies
about how not to become cesspits of uh
denialism and other types of
misinformation yeah no and uh you know a
lot of when you look at the emails uh
there's also an hour and a half long uh
discussion that uh Zach weismiller and I
did with Robbie uh last week's recent
live stream you can go to reason.com and
our videos chat uh vertical our YouTube
channel reason TV
um and listen to that the people at
Facebook were absolutely going out of
their way to saying what about this what
about this like you know and they were
looking for guidance and it makes a
certain amount of sense to go to the
government agency that is charged with
you know actually coming up with the
best policy for this type of stuff and
to be a Clearinghouse for the best
information to do that you know on some
level that's responsible where things
get uh complicated uh to build on what
Catherine was talking about is first the
CDC has been a terrible broker of
information particular particularly
because they don't really acknowledge
the limits of their own knowledge at any
given point in time that was especially
true during covid where you know not
even as much on information but on
things like testing protocols and and
whatnot they you know they acted very
poorly and they never really explained
the limits of their knowledge so that's
a big problem that you're relying on and
you know an expert agency that turned
out to be really bad at it and then on
top of that the lack of transparency in
all of this I think is as important if
not more important with readers because
the fact of the matter is it's one thing
if social media platforms and this is
completely suffer from the question of
whether or not they have the right to do
this but when they deamplify or you know
throttle the reach of certain types of
information or ban people or Shadow ban
in the case of Twitter and things like
that without kind of acknowledging it um
that is I think kind of unforgivable
from a social media point of view like
you know nobody uh you know like when
restaurants serve certain types of meat
but not other kinds of meat or they
refuse to do you know serve something
they kind of talk about it they promote
it um part of the problem and I think
part of the loss of faith in social
media is that we don't know what's going
into their decision-making apparatus and
then they lie about it after the fact
and that's that's a that's a big issue
right here I would add to the CDC
mishandling of information
Rochelle wolinski the director
uh repeatedly just miss citing and
drawing the wrong conclusions from any
number of studies having to do
especially in school settings masking in
school settings Jacob solemn has written
repeatedly about this but when you can
see right there the Machinery working in
such a way where they're trying to
maximally bolster
um their outcome of how they want your
behavior to be shaped by misstating to
the point where the researchers who did
the original studies were like stop it
then that has a deleterious effect Peter
building on that a lot of this activity
from the Biden Administration comes from
July 2021 when search and general vivec
Murphy uh did his uh announce that he's
gonna do a whole of government you know
confront Health misinformation task
force or movement
um yeah the White House Press spokesman
Jens saki at the time warning that
Facebook needs to move more quickly to
remove harmful posts and she was even
like pressuring Spotify to do something
about Joe Rogan and then of course as
Katherine mentioned uh President Biden
um infamously said that social media is
killing people
um a lot of this activity took place
then a lot of the social media companies
Banning people took place then I'm going
to ask you to table the Free Speech
argument for a moment put that aside and
put on your public health and health
policy hat from a health policy point of
view both for covet and future Public
Health pandemic especially crises what
is wrong with that particular approach
well one thing that's notable is that
much of this uh the timeline that you're
pointing out here is all after the
vaccine was available and after people
could make choices for themselves about
whether or not they were going to get
vaccinated and what they were going to
do with their lives and so that was the
point to me at which it was pretty clear
that there was no longer like a real
debate to be had about what we should do
uh in terms of covet policy and pandemic
response and I I still think that there
are some legitimate arguments to be had
about what we should have done in March
through of 2020 through early 2021 when
the vaccine was not available to most
people but once the vaccine was
available to most people which is
sometime around April May June of 2021
right that that cluster of months
depending on exactly who you are and
exactly where you live that to me like
is the point at which the government
should have said here's the vaccine
here's the evidence for why we think
it's good and why it works right like
this this is why it's good for you you
should take it run ads if they want
people to take it and then and then that
should have been that and what's notable
is that all of this stuff happened
afterwards
um in part because you know some of the
original claims about the vaccine did
turn out to be overblown um right the
vaccine was not able to quickly adapt to
some of the variations the the um uh the
Omicron you know that sort of thing if
you remember that and so the the
reopening that that people had expected
uh with a vaccine coming online you know
sort of It kind of we kind of reopened
and then especially in blue States and
blue cities we didn't uh for the second
half of 2021 there were still mask
requirements there were still in some
cases uh you know sort of limitations on
on stuff that people could do uh and I
think that that was that was the period
where
the most obvious mistakes in retrospect
uh were made
uh Catherine I'm gonna invite you to uh
to challenge your Percocet adult brain
um we talk a lot on this podcast and a
reason about section 230 about the
distinction between platform and
Publishing or the alleged distinctions
and that kind of thing
um and we uh argue uh constantly on the
side of uh people who publish on the
internet should not be held liable for
their commenters and and such like
um this that approach I would argue uh
turns a lot of websites and social media
or classic of this to become essentially
third-party platforms right
um and uh so what the analogy I would
like you to reflect on is is it not the
case that some of the worst bits of
third party of worst bits of government
overreach federal law enforcement
overreach I don't know gag orders on
people to talk about investigations of
their commenters happen right there in
the third party things it's it's when
the feds say look National Security is
making us want to crack down on bank
accounts and they go there uh if that's
the case is there is there a useful
analogy to be analogy to be drawn
including in such a way to try to win
over Skeptics who think this is a
nothing burger that the social media
companies are out there trying to figure
out misinformation when governments find
that third party person to lean on the
government leans on the third parties in
a way that is contrary to the spirit of
the Constitution yes no I mean I think
that like that portrait of the world
that you just painted is why there are
so many people who are Libertarians or
libertarian adjacent who are so hyped
about crypto and blockchain right I mean
that's like that feels like the place
where the answer will be now maybe
that's wrong in the end right but even
when you think about the power of these
third parties they that you're
describing
there are still many many many more
nodes many many more paths to get
information from point A to point B than
there were pre-internet and I think
that's the thing that people kind of are
a little bit a historical about or or
kind of historically illiterate about
when we're complaining about this like
it used to be
that if the government didn't want
something published they only had to go
beat up a couple of guys you know they
only had to go be like lightly menacing
at the club to a couple of guys and and
I think that this same Dynamic has
always happened like Jaw boning is not
new
um it's it's it is being practiced
differently right now and um and so
we're thinking through well you know
what is the remedy and and you know I
think it's easy to forget
we have to keep fighting these battles
in the courts and everywhere
about what the limits are of prior
restraint about what the limits are of
kind of government using third parties
to throttle speech directly or
indirectly
um we didn't like invent this with the
pandemic we didn't invent this with
Facebook we didn't invent this with
Hunter Biden's stupid laptop and
um and so I think like that's it's
important context I also think that
there's you know there will always be
choke points and that you know the fact
that we are having this conversation
broadly
reminds us that even if Facebook or
Twitter or whoever had taken a really
aggressive approach you know even if
Twitter had said we are anybody who
writes the words lab leak is off our
platform permanently
that would not in fact have stopped
people from thinking and knowing and
talking about the lab League Theory and
I think that's you know this is where
you get into this kind of like Public
Square public utility kind of messy
argument that people want to make around
the section 230 debate which I think is
pretty misguided I I just don't think
that's the right framework
because we have a Public Square and it's
not any one platform it's it's bigger
broader much harder to regulate thank
God it might actually be useful to just
provide a little bit of background on
job owning since that came from the
1960s and 1970s when presidents Lyndon B
Johnson and Richard Nixon used what was
then termed job owning and that was a
sort of Novel term back then to try to
argue companies into reducing prices as
a way of combating inflation and so this
was right so in 1969 I just wrote about
this in the magazine a few months ago in
1969 a time described job owning as
White House pressure on specific
Industries against against specific
price increases and that was like that
was the the maneuver that they had that
they felt like they could use to try to
fight inflation because they were just
going to say well for the good of the
country you can't raise prices even
though all the prices on their inputs
for these companies were going up and
then of course it didn't work very well
and Biden did that too with the job with
the um with the gas prices right I mean
he he got up he got up there and said
you guys with your corner gas station I
guess you know and and also obviously
bigger corporate entities like you
you're the ones who are doing the bad
thing here
stop it um and you know knowing that he
had really no legal power to to do it I
think gave those gave those business
owners the kind of fortitude to resist
it's a little less clear in the case of
the social media platforms where the
power of the government starts and stuff
I I would actually say that if you look
at the trajectory of jawboning um it's
actually it's a little bit concerning
because it starts with presidents saying
look you've gotta not raise prices and
then that doesn't work and so that leads
in 1971 to Nixon imposing wage and price
controls and like that was the next step
after jawboning failed I think the uh
you know the big takeaway for me from
both the Facebook files and the Twitter
files is less about what the government
was doing because says Catherine is
right to stress you know it wasn't the
government was saying if you don't do
this you're gonna get in big trouble or
anything like that it was actually the
way in which the social media platforms
which are increasingly or or you know
off oftentimes totally staffed by people
who had been in government recently and
are going back there at some point the
way that they were calling on the
government to give them direct guidance
or like you know please help us out with
this or you know in the case of the
Twitter files the stuff that was most
amazing was the way that the internal
communication showed that people were
ready to make a decision and figure out
how to justify it later according to the
terms of service you know what what is
more likely to be controlled is not the
government per se but these social media
platforms and how they respond to their
users either staying there calling for
change or leaving and to me that's the
most uh you know kind of disturbing
thing is that this was not
um you know it wasn't like the
government pushing on a closed door
Facebook had opened the door and was
saying hey what about this what about
this what about this tell us what to do
what is what should we be doing again
some of that is understandable you know
they're trying to be a good corporate
Citizen and everything but you know the
problem I think in this case is less
government and it's more the way these
companies are run uh oftentimes at odds
with what either the founders or even
the uh you know the the main Executives
want out of this stuff Nick I think
that's right I mean in some ways right
like the hard thing for Libertarians to
reckon with here is that uh these
companies are staffed by ex-government
employees and people who are quite to
the left of the average voter who
believe that government is good and like
knows best and like and they are attempt
and so they seek out this information
it's in many cases it's not bullying at
the same time at the same time it's not
just that President Biden has said uh
that these these companies are literally
killing people or whatever it is that
you know the quote exactly was it's that
top White House aides are saying things
like certainly they they as in social
media companies should be held
accountable you've heard this president
and speak very aggressively about this
he understands that this is an important
piece of the ecosystem when asked about
section 230 which is an important
liability protection that for um for
online companies as well as for
individuals and so there are if not
explicit threats being made towards
specific companies there is certainly
open talk about changing the law because
the sense is that social media companies
are doing wrong
Catherine you were budding in there for
a second basically to make the same
point that I I really do think the the
background noise of potential you know
change in the legal system can't be
disregarded here and that's that was why
I initially made this assignment to
Robbie you know a few months back was
how do we capture that how do we think
about that you know when there is always
when there are always a couple of bills
floating around Congress that threaten
to change the legal status of the speech
that is happening on these platforms and
change the liability that the platforms
might bear it's just not it's just not
right to say
you know the real the the problem is the
the ideology or the culture of these
companies alone because it doesn't exist
in a vacuum and this ultimately is the
case for smaller government right you
can't predict the ways in which just a
big powerful sort of chaotic state
will change Behavior you can't always
see the straight lines but you know it's
there it's this Menace that lurks over
every corporate decision and and I just
think you can't underestimate it
I don't think I I agree with that and
I'll just add that you know this is also
from a Libertarian point of view this is
what is important though is to
understand how power operates and I
think a lot of our discourse but a lot
of other libertarian discourse at the
beginning of covid or even before was
like well the government is the bad
actor the government is always the bad
actor and while we are finding out more
and more and again I think that's what
these internal documents in this kind of
force transparency is good at is that it
it complicates that narrative
tremendously this would be like finding
out you know that the uh F uh that the
New York Times or the Washington Post
was checking in with the government
about the Pentagon papers or something
like that we have this theory that you
know media companies even social media
companies are somehow bulwarks against
um you know control of free speech or
something like that and what these
things do is they show that the culture
of Facebook uh the culture of Twitter
and things like that actually does
matter a lot because that that could be
the stopping point against the
government uh attempt uh you know by the
government to rewrite laws in a way that
really constrained free speech and I and
again the other thing is you know what
social media really needs to do is to
come up with a way of being transparent
about its decision making in a way that
doesn't you know up its secret you
know uh uh formula for algorithms and
stuff like that but makes people feel
comfortable and secure and confident
that they are not uh you know that
they're not being uh Shadow banned that
they're not being silenced that they're
not being completely reduced or kicked
off platforms for totally arbitrary
reasons isn't that just a market
opportunity though for competitors to
provide that no not really I mean it is
it is and it isn't like Mastodon I mean
you know first off one of the reasons
why Facebook and Twitter uh are popular
and Instagram is because they have
massive audiences and also because they
promise something like free and equal
access to audiences and things like that
you know I I mean we can talk about
decentralization et cetera but we
already see this at Mastodon you know a
bunch of the Mastodon uh you know
confederated uh servers and stuff like
that you know restrict people completely
I mean there's like certain you know
they just have like total ban lists on
on whole other servers on that so I I
don't you know it's good it's great and
there are a ton like the energy as I
think you guys were both saying has
already started moving to more encrypted
or smaller scale places that can't be
shut down but that's not going to
replace the function of Facebook or
Twitter which is partly to reach a
massive centralized audience
and even those uh decentralized places
can be vulnerable to government pressure
as we saw definitely in the Canadian
truckers uh strike or or protest of last
February when the government of Justin
Trudeau whose name I just want to say
Pierre every single time or Mackie the
better Trudeau
um uh went after people who thought that
they were conducting their uh business
via the blockchain or at least through
Bitcoin and things like that and um and
found out the hard way that uh that
money in many cases was not safe
um so yeah they'll find ways they will
probe the defenses one uh possible
observation knitting together all three
of your points of view is that
um there's a cultural component here I'm
thinking of like why was jaw boning
created and of course I haven't uh read
Peter's feature and uh and not
necessarily soliciting an answer from
Peter at this time but why was jaw
boning a term that felt like it needed
to be created in 1969 well because there
was a sense that hey wait a second the
president is doing something that's a
little bit a little bit unseemly
shouldn't be out there like putting
pressure on individual companies imagine
that now imagine that as a concept that
concept is dead there's nobody who
really uh in any organized way there
isn't a cultural taboo there isn't a
governing political cultural taboo
against presidents jaw boning
um the private companies all the time
now forever unless there's a large
cultural change and that's generally
true of free speech as well it's another
topic we've been talking about a lot
over the last several years on this
podcast is that in many ways what the uh
companies that Nick is criticizing uh
and that Peter is rightly point acting
out their cultural composition
they could be actually acting like way
too many Americans want them to act
Americans are becoming more censorious
over time and want to use speech as a
weapon
um or at least the the blocking of
access of speech as a weapon and it's
bad and uh man we got to change the
culture just like David Crosby wanted us
too all right we're going to uh end that
looks like the culture changed him Matt
Welch
all right man that that's a rabbit hole
that's just gonna produce so many bad
songs on and I recommend people go
listen to Nicole espion political beats
talking about the birds
um uh of uh from a couple years back or
whatever all right we're going to
speaking of Canada read uh out our
listener email of the week here in a
moment but first
friends you might think you've done
everything in your power to ensure your
family in case of a medical emergency
but what many of us don't realize is
that health insurance won't always cover
the full cost of for example an
emergency medical flight
if you require air transports even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where air Medcare Network comes in when
you sign up to become a member of The
airmed Care Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
a provider airmed care transports more
than 100 000 patients each and every
year that's about a dozen just during
the duration of this podcast and this
peace of mind for you and your whole
family can be yours beginning at the low
low price of just 85 dollars a year but
wait listeners to the round table can
get gift cards with their new
memberships for up to fifty dollars
through either Visa or Amazon simply
visit airmedcarnetwork.com reason use
the offer code reason and start
protecting your family do it today
you'll be glad you did all right
reminder email your short queries to
Round Table
at reason.com there was a funny one that
came in uh the other day of someone
saying why does everyone who sends email
I have to write an essay which is mean
uh but also a little bit funny this one
is not an essay and it comes from Sam
Kerr who writes hi all long time
listener and super fan of the show from
up here in Canada
a enjoy hearing a Libertarian
perspective that is so absent from 99.5
percent of our discourse I appreciate
the decimal accuracy there does the
round table have any thoughts on current
Canadian politics particularly the
ascendancy of the kind of libertarian
pierre-polivia
that's how you do it to the Helm of the
conservative party uh to challenge
Justin Trudeau we're currently going
through contortions of a ridiculous
federal gun ban a centralizing and
patronizing national government and a
populace that can't get enough of
experts say takes can a liberty-minded
party ever be successful in a country
like Canada that leans somewhat towards
social democracy and is skeptical of
markets Catherine what say you
I must admit to not paying a ton of
attention to Canadian politics but what
I do have is immigration policy Envy uh
about Canada every single time I see
anything about the way that Canadians
are talking thinking about immigration
policy and trying to shape their policy
I think like that makes more sense
I don't often think that about you know
whatever little tidbit of Canadian
politics I'm hearing for instance the um
you know the human rights tribunals uh
that you know seem to like string people
up for casually using the word Gypsy I
mean there's a bunch of crazy stuff
happening up there as far as I can tell
but they you know even just Justin
Trudeau is out here saying last week or
whatever we're gonna dramatically expand
quotas for uh lots of different types of
visas we didn't do this lightly but
Canada needs workers and we think that
we can absorb these people into our
culture like yeah
please that thank you would love to have
it
um
so I I guess that's that is my main
contribution is to the extent that
Canada seems to be able to have that
conversation I guess it gives me a
little bit of Hope for
you know a more libertarian or kind of
more open approach um in other areas of
their Politics as well but um I am far
as an expert
uh Peterson's Catherine didn't answer
the question I'm going to step on Ty uh
what can you answer the question uh so
if the question is does the round table
have any thoughts on current Canadian
politics
or maybe not so
the reason that like the Michael
kinsley's old joke about the most boring
possible headline in journalism is
worthwhile Canadian initiative and like
like no one is gonna read that story and
no one does read that story uh look I
guess what I would say is my read of the
situation in Canada is it's not entirely
unlike what you just said Matt about
um about the public and and Facebook and
social media companies to some extent
Canada has the government that its
citizens want and Canada Canadians are
just much more okay with deferring to
Authority and to Public Health
authorities and there's just much less
controversy there's obviously not none
as the trucker protests uh you know made
clear at the same time culturally Canada
is just much more sort of okay with like
yeah the government's going to make
decisions and then like you won't be
able to do some stuff and some people
have to do some things that they might
not otherwise have done and like taxes
will be higher in most of the you know
the healthcare system will be will be
run by the government and that's just
how things are going to be and to the
extent that reformers uh can make a
difference I think it is that that it is
not going to be primarily on a sort of
big
um ideological uh uh sort of case for
reforming government it's going to be on
practical initiatives that actually make
people's lives better and that can that
that can be demonstrated to make
people's lives better and I think that
you know sort of people like yes of
course I am motivated by ideology and
sort of a big picture vision of how the
world works and how government you know
should be um and and how it works best
and when it doesn't you know how it
doesn't work and how it fails but I
think most people and especially in a
place like Canada are going to be
motivated by does my life feel better
now after this law Pastor after this
person was elected than it did
beforehand and that's the question that
people looking to make inroads into
Canadian politics should be asking
Nick will your answer reference Canadian
comedians or rock musicians I I was
going to talk about old Expos players
Matt although they're almost all from
America originally so it included
lacondaunch yes I tried to Rusty stab
uh who uh you know uh ended up playing
for so many good teams uh Canada I was
checking this out though uh part of the
problem is like Canada has some obvious
issues which come up in the American
context uh Canada according to the
Heritage Foundation which would have
every reason to put down Canada Canada
is 15th on its uh uh index of economic
freedom the U.S is a lowly 25th Canada
is the best country in the Western
Hemisphere for economic freedom
according to the Heritage Foundation
they pioneered League like National
League weed legalization they're great
on drugs as well as immigration and a
bunch of other stuffs they had basically
a third the number of people per capita
die from covid as the U.S so uh you know
like they didn't have the economic
crisis that we had in 2000 uh 2008 and
things like that
um so you know Canada's doing a bunch of
stuff right it's because it is a
destination country for a lot of really
talented uh immigrants and people from
around the world this guy and how do you
pronounce his name though Matt Welch the
Canadian I would do it
okay very good he sounds he sounds
Dynamite though because he's pro-crypto
he's pro-immigration he's pro-choice
he's anti-vaccine mandate uh I wish he
would emigrate to the United States and
change the Constitution and become
president here
um I think that
um Canada you know the the wheels are
somewhat coming off of their Health Care
System but that has become a point of
national pride uh he's also against uh
the uh the uh you know doctor assisted
suicide law in Canada which I think is
interesting there's a lot of weird
going on about that
um but as Canada starts to supplement
its fully state-owned you know no Escape
Health Care system with Market uh you
know Market informed Alternatives I
think this guy has has a real
possibility but I mean what he's going
to be doing is taking a Canada from good
to great and that might be harder to do
than you know a failing country like the
United States from bad to you know maybe
passable but uh you know Canada is uh is
not as bad as we like to think when we
when we hold on to one you know part of
the Canadian moose and say this is the
whole thing I'm just a a heartened that
a semi-libertarian leaner or politician
up there has a French surname it's
usually from the Edmonton type of people
who come up with that stuff uh I would
recommend people to read uh our
dynamites I believe November 2010 issue
how to slash the state featuring The
horrifying uh fingers of Catherine mengu
Ward it's three literally in three days
in 3D uh and uh there's a piece there
called it can happen here uh in which
people talk talk about various case
studies that have happened where
government spending has actually been
reduced in semi-normal countries in one
of those cases I was by it was in Canada
um and as written by the great David
Henderson who doesn't get enough credit
just in general for being a great person
and a great public policy uh
conversation from Canada right so yeah
so he's obviously an apologist but he
pointed out in his piece that from 1992
to 2001 Canadian spending on federal
programs fell from 17.5 percent of GDP
to 11.3 percent they they had a budget
surplus for more than a decade uh and uh
in a row
um when government dealt with 68 of GDP
it went down to 29
um and this was done by liberal
politicians uh as much as anyone else
there's
um uh some tax increases that were
associated with that but a lot of of
actual real year-on-year government
spending cuts so it can happen
um as ever I'm uh I'm more hopeful about
libertarian policy aims individual goals
than political parties so maybe that can
happen
there maybe can happen here although
these days I don't have a whole lot of
faith in that all right uh let's go to
our second half of the show topic which
I'm absolutely not filibustering about
while I'm
um clicking trying to remember what it
was
a choice week my friends
I just want to make sure that I'm
orienting the conversation Nick
anchoring it uh correctly it is national
school choice week uh which does uh by
virtue of its very uh good naming uh it
doesn't require any explanation it's not
it's national school choice it's an
annual event that's what it does uh
we've been at reason I have been a
co-sponsor of this a participant in this
for a good long time
um Catherine uh can you explain as the
editrix uh the purpose and practical
effect of our involvement with the
yellow scarfers
um and then perhaps lead us in a round
of personal testimonials about about how
your education experiences however
interpreted have shaped your attitudes
about
as former Reasoner Corey DeAngelis says
17 times a day funding students instead
of systems yeah
um I will strive not to tweet that
phrase 17 times a day although it is a
good and important phrase so uh you know
reason uh kind of takes this opportunity
every January to do a little cluster of
Journalism around school choice because
the thing about it is this has been a
huge Victory right like school choice is
a little idea that got hatched out of
you know Milton Friedman's fevered brain
and that sounded absolutely bananas
specifically the ideas about
um using vouchers and Charters to expand
choice for people who are within or
adjacent to the public system
and it's really a classic example of
like that sounds insane until you do it
and then it's just an ordinary part of
the fabric of our educational system but
it can be easy to kind of take that
victory for granted and also uh
education stories you know they tend to
be they tend to kind of follow a little
bit of a template right you find a
family you tell their story and
um you know people on every side of this
debate just use stories for their own
ends um we are we are not immune from
that but I think it's good to take a
minute and just kind of look at the look
at the progress that we've made I am
definitely a person who has benefited
from school the school choice that um
that people with money have always had
which is that my kids now go to private
school but
um but that you know kovid really did
make people rethink a lot of this and in
particular that we've moved you know a
lot of the energy was in the charter
school space and that we're now moving I
think a little bit more toward variants
of vouchers education savings accounts
that kind of thing
that has long been championed by reason
was considered a more extreme version I
think by some people
um because it is just taking a chunk of
public money and handing it to parents
to do what they think best
um and that makes a certain type of uh
education bureaucrat nervous and makes
me happy that they're nervous
part of that is goosed by the Supreme
Court decision last year saying that
public money can be used in in religious
and parochial education and now we've
got school choice I mean this week this
month uh bills in Florida Utah Indiana
um there's basically a dozen or so
states that are are in the process of
thinking about it in addition to Arizona
and West Virginia who have already done
it uh Nick can you
um give us some reflections of your long
work in this category but also uh
perhaps even your personal experiences
and how it shapes uh the way that you
look at it uh well I am a victim of
school choice my parents exercise uh
what in retrospect is just a really bad
decision I grew up in Middletown New
Jersey uh where at the time the teachers
had the highest average pay in all of
New Jersey which is uh recently ranked I
think by Heritage again as the worst
state for school choice in the country
but my parents chose to put me into a
mediocre parochial school system and
that actually uh stuck me with the bill
for my last year of high school so they
you know I don't know what my parents
were doing but I celebrate their ability
to control my education if only I had
gone to a different uh If I Only Had I'd
gone to better funded more academically
rigorous Public Schools I probably
wouldn't be talking to you guys right
now and so you know I'm thinking a lot
about this during school choice week
um but
um eight states have esa's which as
Catherine was saying are is really kind
of where the action is and this
generally what it does is it takes the
state contribution to a kid's school uh
to a kid's education and gives it to the
parents to go to a public school to a
private school to tutoring service to
pretty much depending on how the laws
are into anything the parents say is an
educational uh kind of enterprise
making also homeschooling and things
like that it's pretty fascinating
Arizona just passed the big law Florida
has one later this week the uh the
recent interview podcast on Wednesday is
with lieutenant governor of Virginia
Winsome Sears who uh this is her pet
issue she was on the Virginia Board
State Board of Education and she has
introduced legislation uh to create
esa's that would give you know people
between about four to six thousand
dollars to spend directly on their kids
education the way they want
um I think it's great it's all long
overdue
um what is interesting is that I think
it's uh it's important to understand
that in an increase in school choice and
right now about uh three quarters of
K-12 students go to traditional assigned
Public Schools a bunch go to school
public schools of choice including
Charters and magnets and things like
that about 10 percent go to a private
tools but when we have Universal school
choice this will be like when we have
Universal choice in religion it will not
it will not mean all of the conversation
will go away it will just mean there
will be many more interesting and
diverse conversations that will inflame
the passions and whatnot but people will
be able to actually
you know live the vision of Education
they want for their kids the kids will
also have a say in this so it's it's all
to the good and it's one of the most
exciting uh pushbacks against kind of
Leviathan over the past in the post-war
era we uh we uh took the number of
school districts from over a hundred
thousand to about twelve thousand I mean
there's just a massive centralization in
K-12 education over the past Century and
that's starting to break up and I think
people who are interested in
decentralization and individual control
and experimentation should be very
excited by school choice I will say also
that the the kind of shift in the debate
about school choice has also just moved
the focus of those who would control
education and I think that's kind of you
know looking ahead to the next five or
ten years that's what I think reason is
going to be covering is
um you know curriculum Wars you know the
the sort of need to increasingly specify
from a high level of government what can
and can't be taught in schools that
receive government money because of
course that's the famous way that you um
get your thin end of your wedge into
private institutions as we've talked
about in many many areas and also you
know to the extent that Charters need to
receive a charter and have that Charter
renewed or that vouchers will need to go
to a approved list of schools the
fight's just going to shift there so I
you know I do think school choice is a
good thing
um and you know sometimes a literally a
life-saving thing for for some kids but
um I also worry about you know it's it's
authoritarians all the way down and so
there's just always going to be a new
place to fight about
who controls the contents and kind of
mode of education and that we're in a
moment where that the location of that
fight is Shifting and that's worth
keeping an eye on Catherine even as
you're saying that it occurs to me you
know there's been the Democratic party
on National level in 10 years has really
flipped on charter schools in particular
back then
um Barack Obama's race to the top was
was about you know it's a smallish
program but it was trying to incentivize
school districts to be uh Innovative in
producing new kinds of schools of choice
and now it is a litmus test where if you
have any pretense of of running for
president or some important thing you
have to be vociferously against Charters
Bill de Blasio former mayor of New York
in a really Dynamite candidate for
president uh he is of Canada
dude like tried to run for Congress in
my district or nearby and not for a hot
minute and like was in fifth place or
something in the dropped out is amazing
but anyways he went in front of a bunch
of Democratic presidential aspirants in
2019 went in front of uh a big education
uh teachers union conference and he
pronounced that he hated charter schools
and uh in New York state where I live
um and this is all approved at the state
level there's been a pretty strong
enforcement on a cap of the number of
charter schools and just by doing that
uh in Democratic polities and the huge
shift that that uh has in Democratic
things I think that is pushing more
people away from any kind of publicly
funded system like that that exercise of
control is just pushing more people out
it's a kind of a classic uh consequences
unattended and otherwise Peter uh do you
want to reflect on your yellow scarf and
uh your personal experiences that make
you treasure it or in next case hate it
sure I love scarves just a kind of
winter weather in general give me a
sweater and a scarf of any color and I'm
happy and that's what school choice is
really about good scarves the swag yeah
I will say as a branding campaign yeah
national school choice week they have
this very bright yellow color they
distribute scarves and signs and they
learn a little dance there's a little
dancing part to it
uh no look the premise the premise of
conventional public education is that
one size fits all that basically every
kid in a defined geographic area should
have something like the same experience
with something like the same curriculum
and I went to a public school and I can
tell you one size does not fit all my
experience was not entirely bad but so
much of it was just a huge obvious waste
of my time and I made that argument at
the time and it was true and I didn't
learn anything from me from many many of
my classes now partly that was because I
intentionally set out not to learn
anything I just didn't pay attention I
read books that I wanted to read and
wrote things that I wanted to write and
sort of wasn't particularly involved
with it but the stuff that I was being
sort of tasked with learning in
particular the sort of core educational
requirements of the State of Florida in
the mid-1990s as just a bunch of obvious
nonsense especially for someone who had
very clear interests and abilities and
so the parts of of school that were that
were good were for the most part the
parts that I got to choose in particular
the band in acting programs that at
right the the extracurriculars uh though
they were you know part of the uh part
of my daily school day I had an hour of
band every day and then I had an hour of
you know in an acting class my Junior
and senior years and those were the
parts where I actually learned something
in part because I was invested in those
things because I had chosen these were
the classes that I thought were
important and interesting and I wanted
to succeed in them and so I think this
is like so much of you know school
choice we talk about you know oh this is
better for families who they get to sort
of pick like it's just better for
students when students who are not
necessarily motivated by a traditional
conventional sort of here's your sort of
core courses education when those
students get to pick the things that
they want to do and like and are
actually personally invested in it and
so we can I think we can do a lot more
to motivate kids who are not necessarily
doing super well at school and I say
that as someone who was not a great
student in high school
um it like if I had had more opportunity
to be involved in picking and sort of
and sorting through what I what I got
out of school that I feel I mean in my
experience the parts that I was involved
in were the parts that I was just much
better at and that I got a lot more from
and that I succeeded at
Matt if I may uh other uh video products
or uh that are coming up for national
school choice week or school choice week
uh we've got a video that I did with
Justin Zuckerman about three great
fictional schools that we all wanted to
attend which gets to some of what Peter
is talking about
um and it is kind of fascinating I've
long been amazed at this you know that
we take for granted that school is a
version of prison or Orwell's 1984 uh
that you suffer through and that instead
of like doing it different for your kids
you kind of like replicate that system
uh you know which is is not serving
people particularly well uh you
mentioned New York State Matt last year
for school choice week we did a video
about uh based on reason Foundation uh
uh reason Foundation report New York
State spends on average thirty thousand
dollars a year per student and their
kids are so far below competency and
read
it is astonishing like there is no way
you couldn't give every kid in
New York 30 grand and tell them to be
reading at it you know at a at a senior
and high school level at the end of that
year even if they're four years old but
schools get 12 12 whacks at that and
fail uh but then we also have a great uh
live stream Zach wise real internet on
Thursday with Robert pondicio who is an
education Analyst at the American
Enterprise Institute as well as the
Fordham Institute actually taught in the
South Bronx in really tough schools and
he is at Absolute uh champion of school
choice but is also a Critic of the way
that most schools of choice are run
that's going to be an electrifying
conversation on Thursday
um just building on what you just said
nick uh strikes me I just about like the
pattern uh following and also the thirty
thousand dollars
um I'm into our family's in a similar
situation of Catherine where uh because
of pandemic and other things pulled at
least one of our two kids so unclear
about the second out of the public
system and put it in the private system
it in the private system and uh it costs
less than those thirty thousand dollars
as a matter of fact and we reflect
constantly about how much better that
place is it's incredible how much better
that place is than what we and we pulled
her from a school that is widely
considered one of the best in New York
City in the public system
um and it's just remarkably better and
it makes me think about the the kind of
pattern behavior Nick that like there's
some Stockholm syndrome associated with
this like uh I one of the breed of
libertarian that annoys me the most and
if we can just go ahead and start going
down this path how much time we got
um
Thicket that'd be the one uh you know if
you talk about if you criticize the way
that the public school system works in
New York City they'll either say serves
you right for going to government
schools
or surgery for living in New York City
um and these are the types of people who
um I I predict don't have great um
social skills just evidenced by their
social skills
um but also that they kind of have a
point in the sense only in the sense not
in interpersonally but in the way that
everyone's brains are just kind of
hardwired by having gone through it of
like that's normal this is normal I went
when I I went to Magnet School
uh you know Blue Ribbon School in Long
Beach California and uh and it was a
little program within it and I think
there's a little cluster of me and a
couple of other kids who because
everyone's dad was an aerospace engineer
their everyone was really good at math
um and uh and they ran out of math to
teach us by the time we were in third
grade in a in the k-6 uh and so we
because of that we either threatened or
or executed I don't know I wasn't really
in charge of it like at least two
different lawsuits against the against
the city we became pariahs within the
schools that we went to especially in
junior high school teachers treat us
like crap whatever it was this long
drawn out thing that at the end of it
made me hate math uh which is something
that I grew up loving and uh in all of
this and what do I do when we have kids
um Grant's my wife is French and it goes
through and they have a pretty generally
excellent uh public sector and and
school system compared to America's
um we're like oh definitely have to send
our kids to public schools that's like
with it's really important not to like
go to some you know uh artsy fartsiery
fairy uh type of uh private system you
know you gotta go through the public
thing it's like what is that
um and so now I'm feeling a sense of
guilt that our oldest kid uh has been
through the public school system this
whole time so it makes me want everybody
else like Catherine
uh feels uh to have the opportunity to
enjoy what we have enjoyed give them the
money let them choose
um and they can have these great
Reflections on a daily or weekly basis
if it works out well
um that uh they feel like they're
getting a better bang for their Buck
than funding
the systems instead of the students and
that's the memo um all right let's go to
our end of uh podcast what we have been
consuming in the cultural Arena Peter do
you want to lead us off yeah I read
bride's head Revisited by Evelyn wah
it's pretty good
it's a novel from the 1940s
there's uh there's some good sentences
in it
yeah it's a it's a yeah it's a great
book about some no not just good I mean
I that's like as understated as I can be
some shockingly spectacular sentence
work on almost every page that just kind
of kind of blew me away for 400 Pages or
so and it's a great novel about middle
age and life and regret and love and
forgiveness and uh the existence of God
and faith and uh war and
you know getting older and uh and
there's even a little there's a great
little bit uh about um about education
since we're talking about that so I will
it's like uh I was really tempted to
just bring in a long list of quotes to
read but I will just read one here the
trouble with modern education is you
never know how ignorant people are with
anyone over 50 you can be fairly
confident what's been taught and what's
been left out these young people have
such an intelligent knowledgeable
surface and then the crust suddenly
breaks and you look down into depths of
confusion you didn't know existed it's a
good book folks it's a good book I am so
interested to see what it looks like
um when a man in his 40s makes bridehead
Revisited his whole personality uh since
I knew lots and lots of people in
college who you know were in their 20s
and made red rides had visited their
whole personality I think it's gonna
look uh pretty different and uh I'm
excited to to see how that goes I'm uh
uh glad that you brought that up and
recommended that Peter because I've
always judged that book by its title and
thought ah costume drama enough Merchant
Ivory it starts out with a 39 year old
divorced guy like looking back on his
life and comparing his time in the Army
to a to a marriage that is obviously
ending but has not yet ended and sort of
the the deadness of it all and just sort
of the going through the motions of it
and then he goes back to his college
life and starts to look back on his
friendships and his connections with
this one sort of family and it's very
it's very sort of aristocratic British
conservative nostalgic right like this
is not a Libertarian book and a lot of
in a lot of ways right it is just sort
of about the British upper crust and
sort of what what was lost in the early
part of the 20th century at the same
time
its vision of a good life is incredibly
compelling and the Artistry behind the
the creation of the thing the object
itself sentence by sentence it's so
immaculate and so perfect that I just
sort of
I I couldn't help but fall for its
vision of the world even if it's not one
I fully agree with uh I was uh put a
quick uh word in for the uh Jeremy Irons
Brides had Revisited uh thing which is
clogging up the internet somewhere
uh but I uh I read collaber hate how to
build incredible collaborative
relationships at work even if you'd
rather work alone uh by Deborah mashik
who's a research uh social psychologist
uh who was the first uh executive
director of heterodox Academy and is now
a consultant uh this is a wonderful book
that's out tomorrow I know Deb I
consider her a friend but for all of us
who live in a distributed Workforce and
have to work with other people I highly
recommend reading collabor hate not
crazy about that title uh but it's it's
a very good substantive book about how
to work well with uh with people because
we all have to and part of what she's
talking about here is that we have to
work more and more with other people no
matter what your job is but we do it at
a remove so that the older forms of kind
of collaborating in person have given
way to kind of asynchronous kind of
communication and and collaboration
which makes it so much more difficult uh
to do that because slack email uh even
Zoom calls and things like that are just
relentlessly flat media through which to
you know kind of get done so I
recommend collaborate by Deb mashik
Catherine uh you held your tongue
remarkably during that little
presentation what have you been uh uh
consuming I was so brave Matt thank you
for giving me a cookie
um I read uh like Peter for some reason
I sort of dipped back into uh the
classics I read Salah um by Tony
Morrison it's her second book it was
published in 1973 and
um I read it in high school I was
assigned it in high school
um took absolutely nothing away from it
speaking of uh education where you just
waste your time because you're not the
right person for that curriculum in that
moment
um reread it just now and was blown away
by the the sort of intensity and beauty
of this book
it's basically like Alana Ferrante is my
brilliant friend but make it Ohio
um and uh it's just this very very
concise book it's about 170 pages and
yet manages to be an intergenerational
Saga about you know the economic fate of
a town and female friendship and love
and family and violence and murder and
it's it's it's so there's so much in
these pages that it I I it makes me want
to like
take this book to the authors of other
intergenerational sagas and be like this
do this you don't you don't need 800
Pages Tony Morrison didn't need 800
Pages like here be like Tony
um it just was really really good really
dark very
um
very depressing and
part of my reading of it really made me
reflect on how 10th grade me had no
capacity to Grapple with this book but
it was on the list and so we read it I
will say that this book is now on Banned
Book lists right this is this is one of
the books that has joined
um other other works by Toni Morrison
because it it does have very very dark
themes
um and
um and also has to do with race and so
there's that
um you know the fact that it goes from
mandatory to band uh and back again uh
speaks to at the very least the fact
that maybe we shouldn't have a central
repository for that that sort of thing
um but
um
you know I just I I really really
recommend it if you uh
if you think you know how you feel about
Toni Morrison because someone made you
read it in high school this I think is a
good book to try again there's also a
wonderful forward at least in my Edition
I'm generally anti-forward I am I am
team skip the forward but
um
this one talks about how
she struggled with you know the fact
that people expect Black authors to be
political and then she wrote this book
that was not political and then everyone
reviewed it politically and um how
disappointing that was
um and uh
it really sets the tone to read the book
I think in the right mindset and um and
so if you can get the the addition that
has kind of the green cover with the
swoopy gold lettering that has this
forward in it I would say
um go for that one in particular I also
strongly recommend the forward by wa to
brideshead Revisited where he talks
about having written this in the wake of
World War II
um uh deprivations and uh shortages and
that is he's sort of blames the books um
gustatory Lust For Life which is part of
the pleasure of this book is that there
is so much food and drink and drink and
drink and drink described in this book
so well that uh and in part he says it's
because it you know it was written
coming out of world war II's shortages
and the inability to have things
um and it is it's a wonderful book about
sort of
about small physical Pleasures
especially those that you can consume
uh I yesterday did not read a book
either new or ancient
um but rather I had a couple hours to
kill uh uh in Inglewood New Jersey uh so
let's talk about my life choices that
got me to that moment
um and so a guy what am I gonna do
um let's go visit that thing I've always
driven by and heard about in New York
City
um and never went there because it has a
weird name uh The Cloisters yeah yeah
The Cloisters people like I'm mad you're
becoming so Catholic it's killing me I'm
not being I'm not becoming Catholic I'm
becoming uh objectively Pro really cool
art and random places that don't make
any sense even after you've had it
explained to you so this is at the
absolute top of the needle of Manhattan
it's on a Hilltop overlooking where the
Hudson and uh and Harlem Rivers can flew
um and it's this place that uh so some
dude was a collector of medieval
religious artifacts and art I'm sure he
stole stuff too who knows uh and he had
a place in Manhattan his rich guy
um and he called it The Cloisters and
then he was getting old or maybe he died
and uh this so my history is really good
uh and then John D Rockefeller uh came
in and said hey let's you know we should
make this into like a public museum
let's gather that stuff collect more
like it and let's build a place that
looks like a monastery up on a Hilltop
above New York City
and put it all in there and put all
other types of uh weird art you know
from kind of the 12th century up to the
16th or 17th century and it's just
really uh spectacular setting and and
the level of like uh the wood carving
detail if anyone follows me on Instagram
I have a couple of uh spreads on the art
in there it's really remarkable it's
great it's uh you know I've been to a
lot of churches in in Europe because
that's what you do when you're in Europe
and you're an American go to the church
um and uh and man there's a few places
that I've seen that have such a
concentration of great stuff they have a
big unicorn room with unicorn tapestries
which is apparently the faint most
famous part of the place which why not
um and uh and just a bunch of uh great
weird stuff the place just kind of does
and it's operated by the met the
Metropolitan Museum of Art so here's a
fake Monastery up on a hill built in the
30s by John D Rockefeller to host
medieval European French art and it's
operated by the Metropolitan Museum of
Art
um that's just like New York and some
kind of a bizarre nutshell so uh add
that to your
um you know short list of things that
you do when you visit New York I would
say go visit there must be really
spectacular in the spring too and it's
not all cold and frigid up there you can
walk around the uh adjacent uh Park and
enjoy The Terraces more but super great
Cloisters check it out you'll be glad
you did all right uh thank you for
listening uh listen next week too
because we do this every week on Monday
um you can uh we have a snickering uh uh
sub portal on our site uh region.com
snickering
um and check out our stuff there but
also our podcast the reason.com podcasts
uh if you like what we do as an
organization reason.com donate uh and
we'll catch you back next Monday thank
you good night
[Music]
is